and then the Sunnah of the Prophet slice  island the fact that you have an  application so you have you know the  beauty of this land is that not only is  our text our scripture preserved so  flawlessly but the interpretation of the  scripture is preserved so flawlessly  which is the prophets all along our  DSM's example the Prophet Muhammad peace  be upon him as a high show of the Aloha  and they Allah be pleased with her  explain today you know I explained he  was a walking ad which is so if I can't  understand this word I can just go to  the prophets likes on life likens I can  see even the Sunnah has been preserved  flawlessly